how to buy a house with no money is it
possible to buy a property using little
to no money the answer is absolutely yes
I have done over 500 property
transactions I've been full-time in
property for the last 15 years since
2009 and there's four ways that you can
buy properties without using any of your
own money and in this video I'm going to
reveal everything it's really
interesting because people think you
need a lot of money but that is a trap
because if you want to save up enough
money to buy a house the average house
right now is about £300,000 deposits
going to be about 75 grand for you to
work hard in a job and save 75 grand is
probably going to take you about 10
years by which time house prices have
doubled anyway so now you need to save
up all over again most people don't
understand the correct way to invest in
property and I'm going to show you in
this way how you can literally buy a
house with zero money and you can get
started straight away so if you enjoy
the sound of that hit like let's go the
first way to buy a property without
using any of your own money is to joint
venture with other people and use their
money now you might think that sounds
too good to be true that's not possible
but let me tell you something this is
what rich people do now you might think
well why would rich people use other
people's money to invest in property
when they're rich and they can use their
own money because rich people understand
the power of Leverage if you use other
people's money you can buy an infinite
amount of deals and snowball your
portfolio even Banks do this did you
know that when Banks save your money
they invest it and a lot of the time
they invested into property Lloyd's Bank
their goal is to become the largest
private landlords in Britain how do they
invest in property Lloyd's Bank well we
put our money in the bank and they use
our money and invest it in property make
Sky High returns and give us
0.1% did you realize that you could do
the same thing you can find people that
have got money in the bank whether they
be friends family uncles aunts business
associates or come along to property
investment events and find people that
have got 50 Grand 100 grand and sitting
in their bank and these people a lot of
people that have got money they haven't
got what they haven't got time doctors
lawyers they've got money they've got
savings but they haven't got time so
what you do is you find an incredible
investment opportunities and you partner
with them you say listen I found this
house I've negotiated down to 100 Grand
it needs a big refurb but we're going to
split it into flats and push the value
up and make 100 Grand profit on it it's
all lined up I've found it I've
negotiated it I've got the builders in
place I've got the management companies
in place what if we set up a company you
can loan your money to the company and
then the company can buy the property do
the refurb refinance the house pay you
back and then we'll own the property
together 50/50 that is a good proposal
if you're skillful and you're valuable
then you don't need money because you
can you can put your skin in the game is
your value is your knowledge is your
time is your expertise that is one of
the most easy most straightforward ways
to grow your portfolio and to become
wealthy through property without using
money but instead using time and
knowledge and inclination the second way
is deal sourcing maybe you're not
comfortable or confident to pitch
investors and say let's set up a
business together so you can start by
just simply finding investment deals and
passing them over to investors not
asking for a percentage of the deal not
asking to set a company up in joint
venture with them just charge them a
broker fee charge them a few thousands
this is deal sourcing and good deal
sources are super in demand cuz think
about it if you're a doctor or a lawyer
and you've got 150 Grand in in your bank
and you really want to invest in
property but you don't want to go out on
a Tuesday afternoon in the rain to
potentially have an appointment
cancelled you haven't got the time to
scroll on right move and to ring agents
and to you ain't got the time with the
inclination to do that so what are you
going to do you're going to pay a deal
sourcer the deal sourcer is going to go
out there find the deal package the deal
then present it to the investor and the
investor is going to pay typically about
2% of the purchase price 2% is peanuts
you pay more than that in stamp Duty tax
to the government when you you buy the
house so you're paying 2% but if the
average house is £300,000 that means
you're the deal sourcer I'm making a fee
of how much £6,000 and what have you
done you've just called a few agents
gone out viewed a few houses negotiated
found a deal passed it to an investor
made six grand if you're really terrible
at that business and you're a terrible
deal sourcer and you can only do that
once a month which is terrible you're
going to make six grand a month that is
twice the average salary in the UK for
just finding and selling one deal in a
month then take the rest of the month
off like this is the most simple way if
you're aggressive and you do one one a
week and you make 6 12 24 Grand in a
month now some of you again right now
you're thinking 24 Grand in a month come
on get real yeah very very very
realistic I've got hundreds of students
in the UK doing that kind of money 24
Grand in a month spend half and invest
half and very quickly you've now got a
little part a little deposit where you
can start investing in your own deals
and which deals are you going to invest
in the very best ones that you didn't
want to pass on to investors see when
you're a deal sourcer you're getting
paid to view houses the very best ones
you cherry pick for yourself deal
selling everyone should be a deal seller
number three purchase lease option
agreements now purchase lease option
agreements this might be a little bit
confusing so take note here it's when
you buy a house now but you agree to pay
for it later now this blows people's
minds like how can you buy a house now
and pay for it later and when is later
typically the lease option agreement
later might be 5 years 6 years 11 years
down the line what's the great thing
about doing that the great thing about
doing that is if you buy a house now but
you pay nothing or okay technically you
have to pay1 as a purchase lease option
fee but if you take a house now and you
pay a pound and you have the option to
pay for it in s years what are you going
to do in the meantime between now and 7
years you're going to rent it out you're
going to make money every month and what
are you going to do with that money
you're going to put it into a little pot
and then after seven years that pot is
going to have grown to become what the
deposit to buy the house and what
happens with the house hous generally
over time they go up it's not like
you're buying um a sofa and a green and
this this is very normal to buy things
and pay for them later with sofas and
holidays and cars if you buy a car
typically you know you might buy PCP
you'll buy it now you'll pay a very
small down payment and then you'll pay a
small monthly fee and then in 5 years
time you have the option to either walk
away or to pay a balloon payment and to
buy the car but at the end of the term
what's happened to the car it's gone
down in value and also last time I
checked it doesn't it didn't give you
any rent if you do have a sof for even
more so you do have a holiday buy the
holiday now and pay for the holiday
later but the holiday doesn't exist
anymore but you're so you're paying for
something when it doesn't exist where
with a house if you structure a purchase
leas option agreement with a house
you'll buy it now but by the time you
come to pay for it in five six seven
years it's appreciated in value so
you've benefited from the capital
appreciation but you've also benefited
from the rent and believe it or not this
is a very normal way to buy properties
if you go into a High Street estate
agent or if you're if you ask your mom
or dad or you're at school and you ask
your teacher they'll say you can't do
that m
yeah you can ask a rich person that's in
property it's very very very standard
I've done six purchase lease option
agreements this year on three pieces of
land two hotels and a factory buy now
pay later very standard we had a guy
called Ian Ian Patterson who came to my
property investment crash course in
2017 and he he was with a corporate job
working full-time when he realized that
you could buy a house now and pay for it
later on a purchase his option agreement
he got his first deal and he was like
damn why am I stopping at one he went
and get another one another one another
one another one before he knew it he had
a whole portfolio 1.8 million pound
property portfolio and least option
agreements quit his job working in the
corporate job and was all over the
newspapers everyone was like oh my gosh
he's bought all these houses but it's
very standard for me it's not even
shocking it's normal so study purchase
these option agreements you can come
down and meet me for a whole day at the
property investors crash course I'll
share all day I I mean my attitude is
sometimes people say Samuel if you're so
successful in property if you've done so
many deals why on Earth would you share
on YouTube how you're doing it why on
Earth would you run a crash course for
for a day and charge a pound for people
to come and see you and share and the
answer is because I believe that basic
financial literacy around property
investment and finance I think it should
be available for everybody I think it
should be taught in schools I just built
two schools last year in Uganda on the
basis that I'll pay for the school
building as long as the government would
let me have a say in the curriculum so
the kids could be financially literate
so for me this is a mission so come down
I'll leave a link in the description pay
one we'll spend a day together and I'll
teach you exactly how to do this but
finally step four step four is rent to
rent rent rent to rent is what we call
rental Arbitrage that's where you rent a
property on a company L and you agree to
rent it out at a higher amount now you
don't own the property but you control
it you might have heard them saying own
nothing but control everything some of
the most lucrative businesses in the
world some of the richest companies like
Amazon for example Amazon's probably the
most successful company in the world
Amazon don't own their stock they're the
middleman someone will list something an
independent buyer will list them on
Amazon and then someone will sell it and
they'll be the middle man in between
Uber Uber don't own their cars or their
taxis they're the middleman Airbnb don't
own their hotels they're the middleman
it's very powerful being the middleman
in real estate you can get very very
very rich so if you rent a property
let's say a studio apartment you rent a
studio apartment for £700 a month but
then you turn it into like a mini Hotel
how do you turn it into a mini Hotel
furnish it nicely put a little lock box
outside and put it on Airbnb booking.com
now you rent it out for £100 an hour £1
a night is £3,000 a month now sure you
got costs got bills it's not going to be
100% full but you're only paying £700
for it so the profit which might be
£1,000 every month that's yours to keep
if you do this with just two or three
little Flats you've replaced an average
salary in a job by rental Arbitrage rent
to rent company let so if you do these
four things if you master these four
things you could become extremely
wealthy in property as I mentioned
before if you want to spend a day with
me and you want me to show you I mean
the crash damn I'm literally on the
phone to agents I'm finding live deals
it's almost like you come to my office
and look over my shoulder and watch me
find deals so I'd love to spend a day
with you I'll leave a link in the
description come down to the property
investors crash course let's do deals
together let's get money and let's have
fun I'll see you there Link in Bio God
bless